what's this a clip of JD almost drowning  in four feet of this is maybe the  funniest video I've ever seen here he  goes he's going down a slide and he does  then he falls into the pool and now he's  drowning  stand up well first of all I'm not that  good of a swimmer second of all I can't  see too well going down the slide and I  don't see it I got water going into my  face and I don't see the end of the  slide coming and next thing I know I'm  in water and when you go down to water  by my balance when you go down a  waterslide don't you expect to be in  water eventually oh yeah but I thought I  would go into the water the water is  literally up to his knees and he's  drowning I couldn't find my valve look  at that  [Laughter]